bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dédiée à Spider-Man
across the spider-verse le film est une
véritable masterclass et c'est petit
franchement Sony a frappé très fort et
cela promet du très lourd pour l'avenir
en vrai je partage peu mes ressentis
d'habitude en vidéo car j'aimerais que
l'on se concentre plus sur le
l'or/tory les explications tout ça mais
là le film m'a vraiment marqué c'est une
véritable claque j'ai juste envie de le
revoir perso et franchement je vous
conseille d'aller le voir si vous ne
l'avez pas encore vu bref voilà revenons
quand même à nos moutons nous allons
parler plus en détail de ce que cross
the spider-verse amen comme information
de sa fin également bien évidemment et
essayez de voir ce qui pourrait être
fait pour l'avenir donc vous l'aurez
compris mais je vais devoir spoil bien
évidemment si je veux être libre dans
cette vidéo donc vous êtes prévenus sur
ce si vous êtes prêts on y va bon tout
d'abord il va falloir parler de tout
l'aspect multivers
les deux films d'animation de Sony sont
très sur miles exploite à fond ce
concept et vous le savez ce n'est pas un
hasard en fait dans le premier film
c'était plutôt gentillet car c'était on
va dire la découverte miles apprend à
mieux se connaître il expérimente ses
nouveaux pouvoirs on nous ramène
tranquillement la vibe Spyder vert ce
qui est une thématique forte de
l'histoire de Spider-Man des comics ce
n'est pas pour rien qu'on a aussi vu ce
concept dans nos héros mais voilà cela
reste quand même assez tranquille là le
deuxième film rentre complètement dans
le dur ils ont exploité à fond le
concept du multivers limite autant voire
plus par moment que le MCU lui-même et
par conséquent avec ce qu'ils ont amené
et expliquer il y a moyen je trouve
d'établir certaines choses pour l'avenir
déjà le caractère élu de Miles bon
forcément c'est le héros du film donc
c'est logique que Sony souhaite le
rendre unique mais là dans ce deuxième
campus il y a vraiment un désir de
rendre miles spécial au sein du
multivers premièrement le cas de ses
pouvoirs contrairement à la grande
majorité des autres Spider-Man miles est
capable de générer de l'électricité et
en plus de cela il peut se rendre
invisible lors de la scène d'évasion il
réussit à fuir la totalité des Spiderman
qui le pourchasse au point que
personnellement je trouve cela les
rendait presque ridicule à côté de Miles
mais également il a été capable de
surpasser Miguel au haras alias
Spider-Man
2099 qui est entre guillemets un spider
man vraiment ultime dans le spider-verse
néanmoins le coup de grâce qui pour moi
prouve la place spéciale et le véritable
caractère unique de miles au sein du
spider-verse c'est l'origine de ses
pouvoirs vous l'aurez compris dans le
film mais Miles est une anomalie
ignorée jamais dû être Spider-Man à
cause du synchrotron de Wilson Fizz que
conçu notamment par le scientifique
devenu par la ensuite the spot alias
l'attache l'araignée censé mordre Peter
Parker originaire de l'univers 42 a
atterri dans l'univers de Miles et c'est
lui du coup qui a été mordu et parce que
ce moment clé de l'histoire a été changé
cela a découlé sur la mort du Peter
Parker de la réalité de Miles faisons
devenir miles du coup le nouveau
Spider-Man etc etc c'est l'effet
papillon et là dessus il y a deux choses
hyper intéressantes à souligner
premièrement c'est que Miles se possède
un lien particulier avec le multivers
puisque la source de ses pouvoirs
provient d'une autre réalité ce qui
change complètement des autres
Spider-Man et c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui aura des effets mais
ensuite l'élément qui est vraiment
spécial c'est qu'avec cette origine
miles casse tous les codes comparé à ses
variants pour mieux vous expliquer et
comme la très bien démontré Miguel
l'histoire des araignées est
particulière
Spider-Man est un héros qui doit passer
par des moments clés dans sa vie qui
vont le faire devenir véritablement
Spider-Man ce sont des sortes de points
immuables du temps par exemple la
morsure de l'araignée la mort d'un
proche comme oncle Ben ou bien également
le sauvetage raté d'un personnage clé
traduisant que Spider Man ne peut pas
sauver tout le monde si on prend par
exemple le Spider-Man d'Andrew Garfield
il y a le capitaine Stacy le père de
Gwen dans le premier film puis Gwen
elle-même dans le second tout ça ce sont
des moments clés dans le multivers il y
a clairement une grosse thématique du
destin et encore plus avec le héros
Spider-Man sauf que Miles de par son
histoire et l'origine de ses pouvoirs
aboli tout ça et c'est là où nous
rentrons un peu dans de la théorie que
va-t-il se passer dans Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse dans across the
spider-verse nous ne faisons pas face à
des événements Nexus mais plutôt des
points absolus du temps comme expliqué
Spider-Man doit vivre des moments précis
pour devenir ce qu'il deviendra et le
film nous l'a très bien démontré
notamment avec l'intervention de Miles
sauvant le capitaine de police de la
réalité de pavitre le Spider Man indien
directement après la réalité a commencé
à subir des dégâts donc cela sous-entend
très clairement que la survie du
capitaine était un point immuable de la
réalité de pas vitres mince sachant que
la future mort de son père est le
prochain point absolu de son histoire et
de sa réalité va souhaiter modifier tout
ça nous sommes clairement face à
l'abolition du destin mais du coup s'il
y arrive que va-t-il vraiment se passer
déjà il y a moyen que Miles échoue tout
simplement ce serait un moyen de
l'abaisser pour mieux le remonter comme
ils font souvent pour les héros et
notamment Spider-Man mais au vu de ce
qui se prépare je ne pense pas que l'on
va aller dans ce sens en fait il y a un
autre point très important que nous
devons explorer et c'est le fait que les
productions Sony sont officielles dans
le multivers du MCU et je pense que vous
savez de quoi je vais vous parler Secret
Wars est censé être le dernier film de
la saga du multivers et nous le savons
de par les comics ainsi que grâce à la
série Loki ce sera la guerre
multiverselle et par conséquent
l'effondrement de ce dernier du coup ce
n'est pas un hasard si Sony rentre à
fond dans le concept de multivers par le
biais de cross the spider-verse et qu'en
plus le troisième film est censé sortir
l'année prochaine ils veulent créer un
événement énorme pour préparer leur
futur liés au MCU en fait c'est
maintenant qu'ils doivent exploiter à
fond le multivers qui est encore plus
tôt intact et frais car arrivé aux
événements de Secret Wars tout le
multivers entier sera touché donc je
suppose très fortes chances que Miles va
provoquer quelque chose d'énorme dans le
multivers et que cela va impacter
plusieurs réalités j'aimerais
personnellement vous en parler un petit
peu plus en détail dans une prochaine
vidéo mais il faudra quand même ramener
encore une fois le sujet des incursions
surtout que voilà les lecteurs de comics
je pense que vous savez de quoi je parle
concernant miles de plus dans beyond the
spider-verse il faudra que le film
développe un peu plus Miguel car en soi
nous pourrions le comparer à Kang le
Conquérant miles est peut-être une
anomalie et ses actions ne font pas du
bien aux multivers mais en réalité
Miguel est bien pire en fait si nous
voulons que le multivers restent intact
qu'il n'y ait pas de problème de
temporalité ou que il n'y ait pas
l'empreinte trop forte d'un personnage
dans un autre univers bien la solution
normalement c'est que chacun reste dans
son univers tranquillement si personne
voyage entre les univers il n'est pas
censé se passer des dingueries et du
coup Miguel est le premier fautif
là-dedans si on relativise il est même
la source du problème il a détruit un
univers il est à l'origine du
rassemblement des Spiderman à travers
tout le multivers et il intervient à de
nombreuses reprises dans les dimensions
des autres par exemple c'est à cause de
lui que Miles a découvert que son père
allait mourir donc en soi c'est sa faute
si miles souhaite changer le cours de
l'histoire et au final Miguel se
retrouve à voyager dans l'univers de
miles pour l'empêcher de changer
l'histoire tout comme Kang Miguel est à
l'origine de nombreux problèmes à cause
de ces interventions dans le multivers
et tout comme Kang devenu celui qui
demeure il souhaite résoudre de lui-même
les problèmes est-ce que vous voyez
l'idée enfin j'aimerais qu'on parle
rapidement du fameux projet d'un film en
live action avec Miles morales Sony nous
clairement des choses comme je vous l'ai
toujours dit miles morales et la pièce
manquante du MCU into et across the
spider-verse sont les seules dernières
productions de Sony qui sont liées de
loin avec le MCU seul le multivers les
relie vraiment contrairement à Toby
Maguire ou encore Andrew Garfield qui
sont déjà apparus dans Noé home pareil
pour Venom et ils ont même relié Morbius
par conséquent Sonic et exploite à fond
le multivers avec Miles morales qui est
désormais presque un Spider-Man
ultime comparé à ses compères c'est pour
nous proposer quelque chose d'énorme
dans le futur mais la véritable
interrogation est la suivante est-ce que
Miles morales défile d'animation sera
celui qui interviendra dans le futur du
MCU ou bien est-ce qu'il réserve ça pour
un miles morales différents perso je
pense personnellement qui nous
proposeront une variante de Miles
morales déjà tout simplement car dans
l'identité visuelle des films
l'animation semble faire partie int de
l'univers de Miles on le voit notamment
avec the spot quand il intervient dans
la réalité de Venom où on est dans du
live action ou encore le caméo de Donald
Glover en tant qu'eron Davis et en plus
de cela Sony si je ne dis pas de bêtises
n'a jamais confirmé que Miles faisait
partie de la réalité 1610 ils ont
toujours gardé le secret et justement le
fait que quand mile se trompe de réalité
pour rentrer chez lui en atterrissant
dans la réalité 42 et bien c'est un
moyen pour eux de conserver encore une
fois ce secret qu'il dévoileront très
certainement dans beyond the
spider-verse et si je vous dis tout ça
ce n'est pas par hasard car miles
morales de la réalité 1610 et bien c'est
le Miles morales principales en quelque
sorte comme le Peter Parker 616 il y a
des chances pour que Sony utilise cette
réalité pour le Miles morales en live
action surtout que petit point comics
mais du coup on en parlait tout à
l'heure la réalité 1610 c'est la
dernière réalité existante avec la 6016
à rentrer en collision durant Secret
Wars et par conséquent c'est ce qui va
permettre après toute cette histoire
notamment la fusion des deux univers et
donc la rencontre entre Peter Parker 616
et Miles morales 1610 vivant tous les
deux à terme dans le même monde mais
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
c'est la fin de cette vidéo je suis
désolé si j'étais un peu fouilli par
moment dans mes explications ou dans ce
que je voulais amener a cross the
spider-verse amène beaucoup de détails
et comme je vous ai dit il rentre
complètement dans tout le concept de
multivers il exploite vraiment et on va
pas se mentir que c'est quand même un
sujet un peu compliqué le multivers et
également à vulgariser là dans cette
vidéo je vous ai vraiment amené tous les
éléments que j'estime important que
j'avais en tête mais nous aurons
clairement l'occasion de reparler tout
ça de faire de de belles théories se
concentrer sur des thématiques bien plus
précises et voilà le film est très riche
il est incroyable il y a vraiment
beaucoup de choses à dire sur ce
j'espère que la vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu et un commentaire sur ce que vous
avez pensé du film ainsi que quels sont
vos attentes pour beyond the
spider-verse et surtout bah également
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner allez
c'était tarder rock que le lion hard
soit avec vous
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]